kevin mchale the Hall of Famer NBA on
TNT analyst three-time champ with the
Celtics called last night's Philadelphia
Boston Game one he joins us tonight
Kevin thanks for joining us how
surprised were you with what you saw
last night surprised
especially when I knew that Jalen Brown
wasn't gonna play and they did you know
the Celtics it really is pretty amazing
I mean I know I know that I am an old
Celtic and Danny's a good friend of mine
who runs a team stuff like that but you
know I was watching that team and I'm
thinking no Kyrie Irving you Gordon
Hayward hasn't been around all year long
Jalen Braun goes out you know that you
just when you lose three of your top you
know wing type players it's so hard in
today's game and the self is just on the
way that they have a pretty simple
formula that works very well they have a
bunch of two-way players they get after
you defensively they're they're smart
and they make the three-ball and you
know these guys can defend individually
they keep their man in front eeeh
they're making work to beat him they
have a bunch of guys that are just
scrappy and so but I was surprised I
just I had done a few of the Philly
games in the playoffs and they were
hitting a stride there their ball
movement was fantastic their body
movement just the spacing the ability to
knock down threes by multiple people
and last night none of that really
showed through the only thing that that
that that kind of showed through to me
last night that Philly has a huge
advantage is when Joe LMB just starts
going to work in the post or just you
know there's just no answer for him who
is the most important Celtic know wow
you know what it may sound funny to
probably the most important Celtic might
be deal this guy out there Dell Horford
ljus against Milwaukee L got in the post
he played against all those guys from
Milwaukee they didn't know that they
were so skinny autistic oom-pah-pah
maker and he just took him in the post
and just just bodied them hit him and
hit him and got to the free-throw line
made two and three foot shots all night
long against Milwaukee and kind of
whenever the Celtics needed a hoop they
were able to go to L in the post now
against your wall and beat he just his
post game is going to be minimized just
because Joelle is a really big lanky
good defender
that in that painted area and so all of
a sudden elbows all slice in starts
making three stretches the defense make
his Pat makes passes form on top gets
the ball moving from side to side is a
good pic setter so I would say Al
Horford it have a chance to win this
series Al's going out to really you know
play well every single night in a
victory for the Celtics just because
again there's lack of bodies but because
you're fantastic and Tatum looks nothing
like the rookie Marcus smart goes out
and just makes plays you know beans
comes in off the bench makes a couple
threes they just have large it makes a
big shot just in a part of the game when
their office was struggling and nothing
happened on a possession and Philly look
like they're getting a little momentum
three seconds to go on the shot clock
Larkin makes a big three so they got a
lot of guys playing well for them but I
would say L overall could you see LeBron
fitting in with this 76ers roster yeah I
mean the LeBron fits in anywhere he
wants to fit in because LeBron can have
games where he the bran can take a back
seat which is not doing right now just
because of what the Cleveland knows it
needs him to do so much stuff but LeBron
can take it back see the any point he
wants and just please you know I he's
never been like I got a score I'm a
greedy score if he plays and these guys
got it going jewel and B and go how's it
going he passed but I would say one
thing you know
Simmons is special he didn't play well
last night but Simmons is really special
and taking the ball out of his hands
because LeBron is such a great playmaker
I died you know I I'm not sure if I'm
silly and as crazy to say but as great
as LeBron is that I'm not sure that that
him going to that team really helped in
Simmons become the player that he needs
to be for not for Philly to win next
year but for freely don't have a run
like like I was saying last night turns
during the broadcast
that's Philly in Boston with the use of
the guys they have a chance to make this
a generational type thing like it when I
say generation the NBA it's five six
seven
I mean that says that's a generation in
the in the in the MBA and they have a
chance to be relevant not only in the
Eastern Conference but four
championships over that period of time
and I think LeBron is just that the you
know as phenomenal as the guy is and he
gives them a year or two of you know
probably saying they're the favorites if
they can keep everybody by that man I
don't know if that's interesting because
I'm such a fan of LeBron just because he
can do anything you want on a basketball
floor but he could easily take a
backseat and just come in there and just
help this team get better but you know I
don't know he's Kevin McHale joining us
Continental Tire coaches corner when you
hear the LeBron Michael Jordan
comparisons or argument or discussion
what do you think
well they're two different two different
players I mean you know LeBron is a past
first guy LeBron I've seen LeBron he'll
move the ball you'll do stuff Michael
was a scoring assassin LeBron could
prove the bronze a better passer better
rebounder than Michael Michael just had
that that late-game
unbelievable Drive great one-on-one
player from certain spots on the floor
you know it they're they're really
different so it's always hard I always
say the LeBrons a little bit of a
combination of you know magic and Larry
and just just a unique unto himself
Michael was just a phenomenal scorer
with just a gritty tough you know
take-no-prisoners type attitude and you
know I hit this there's their third
difference what I hear the comparisons
I'm you know two of the top players will
ever have played the game but just
depends on what you like like I always
tell people like if I was playing huh
I'd rather play with LeBron James so
that's why I made like eight in a row
give me my knife when I make money
throwing Michael say hey you know get
behind didn't bird do that to you as
well like what do you always go to you
or what do you say all right you know
hard kill man that's enough
no birdie was birdie birdie was a very
unselfish guy he you know he didn't
force anything if you he takes shots but
if you were hot believe me he was on the
first guys they get Kevin the ball I get
Roberts block get whoever the hot man
the ball was so ya know that was my
Larry when Larry Larry played the game
was very very pure when he when he was
on the floor he just didn't you know he
didn't looked he didn't look to take bad
shots if someone had it going like you
know if we're you're struggling on the
offensive and Larry would search his
offense but if you had something that
worked but that's the way that's the way
we all kind of played if Robert had it
going you know Robert got it so it was
an unselfish group of guys would do you
remember about the locker room after
Michael Jordan scored 63 on you guys in
the garden
did you guys want our aim we all with
the Casey Jones that we better
double-team that guy he's a hell of a
lot better we thought he was because he
had 49 I think in the 45 or 49 in the
first game and honestly I tell people
this all the time we barely game planned
for Chicago they had one like 30 I don't
know at 33 35 games in the regular
season we had 167 we kind of went in
there and said okay look let's just run
our stuff let's take care of what we got
to do let's just be us and we'll be fine
we know will switch on Michael we'll do
some stuff well you know we're not gonna
we're not gonna double-team them and
after that in game 3 uh you know we all
went like okay we got a game plan this
guy and I I know you I know you have a
bunch of guys there to look up stats I
know if you don't know the stat but in
Game three cuz I remember going in there
and and and everybody was all upset cuz
I bought I brought a Dopp kit I didn't
bring my over I didn't bring any clothes
and I was like we're leaving them on you
know gonna play one game or gone and
they were all like you know they almost
beat you as an overtime game and I went
like now we're gonna hammer these guys
are going to go home and they were all
upset the media made a big thing about
me only bringing adopted no no clothes
on the road they said but again you lose
that I guess I smell bad and you know we
beat him and off we went when someone
looked at what he did in the third game
I got all you guys got all the Dan s
over there doing nothing so haven't do
something holy do something for Kevin in
Game three Jordan had 19 points 10
rebounds 9 assists
he was a preteen yeah we double team
them almost every time and just said man
we got to get the ball out of this guy's
hands and so yeah we we shut it we shut
it was shut him down a little bit but I
tell you one thing though that was kind
of I knew he could really blame I just
didn't know he was quite that explosive
and I was kind of startled Michael just
blowing up and and you know just being a
damn nur unstoppable force on the
offensive end
speaking of unstoppable James Harden it
feels like he's in that short on that
short list to your Kevin of unstoppable
guys yes no question James you know
James is funny like most times when you
major
third dribble you're uncomfortable
you're trying to pass the ball you try
on his fifteenth dribble he's starting
to get a rhythm in his legs these
pitter-pattering is going back and forth
and the bar he dribbles in he's got to
step back into driving Anya James is a
phenomenal ISO player I mean he gets the
ball on top and you know and again
everything is relative like I'll tell
you okay really quickly on like Michael
they met do you remember the old zone
rules you couldn't cross the free-throw
line and all this stuff put in and
Michael just took such great advantage
of those rules because you know you'd
get on the right side on the elbow on
the box you couldn't come over it was
all convoluted defensive rules well now
the defensive rules say you can't touch
a player on the perimeter and you know
James is so physical and he's so strong
that it's almost impossible to guard him
because he initiated a ton of contact
and when he was initiating that contact
it just you know it goes in favor of the
offense almost all the time so when he's
up there he's an amazing he's an amazing
flow right now and what makes that whole
flow happen is you watch him he'll make
that step-back three and he's making
that man I tell you what he backs up and
he comes backs up and he comes out your
backs up and he comes out you finally
goes by you make the pass and I think
Clint capela has helped him so much
Clinton's role in clintus staying open
Clint always it was a great kid capela
was lucky enough to work with them for a
while
he's always of presenting itself open at
the rim so James has a bail all when
he's gonna throw that there Hyde to
Clint and cliffs playing well but James
is unstoppable right now and you know
that's it's he's just on he's on a roll
that guys get on you just go like wow
feels like every time we have somebody
on who played against bird we always
asked for their favorite trash talk
story you were there you were you were
in the in the theater every single night
do you have a favorite bird trash talk
story oh my gosh well probably my
favorite one was we were playing in
Phoenix and we were way up we were like
50 up 15 and we have the word for
we were terrible and Larry's bad Larry's
missing shots told it to the other team
throw it in there so grow and they come
back in some house you know they go up
to so we have a play out of bounds play
I'm taking it out and Larry says I'm
gonna bust off the play and I'm just
gonna come out and I'm gonna shoot at
three and I'm like we're down two I'm
like no don't do that I think you should
let sure to please go try to get fouled
let's just get no overtime see if we
can't win this game and Lennie says now
I'm just gonna bust the three on them
and I'm like oh my gosh so he tells us
tells the Phoenix bench tells the
coaches
yeah I'm just fixing to bust the three
on you guys and just go home I'm tired
of this and he gets the ball jumps up
bust the play comes out gets the ball to
slide shoots the ball as the ball is in
the air he kind of turns towards the
Phoenix benches yells told you so Hawker
room he went in and I just started
laughing I was like oh man you know AJ's
just one of those ones where he just
kind of he has supreme confidence and it
was just but I that's the one with you
when you're back in and Larry went in
and said well I won the game in the
first three quarters and I lost it the
third quarter and the fourth core excuse
me
now I wondering at the end he goes my
record tonight is two and one I still
love when he says to Xavier McDaniel ex
I'm gonna get the ball right here and
I'm gonna take a jumper right in the
face I'm gonna make it and then he gets
the ball takes the shot right in front
of Xavier McDaniel and makes the shot
you know and X tells the stories like he
did exactly what he was telling me he
was going to do remember Anthony Mason
just you know just kind of point forward
our guy just big strong guy we're
playing he's in New Jersey now they call
him up and from this one this is from
the d-league or the CBA or whatever it
was called back then and he's sitting
out there and man that guy's like you
know he's got you know muscles
everywhere so before the game Larry look
there you go take Kevin that's a good
look at this guy man and a standard goes
look at all those muscles you know
Anthony Mason is just stand
kind of pose an inhaler looks in because
y'all those muscles aren't gonna help
you tonight
Larry would shoot the ball on y'all
muscles when you were shooting and I
just kinda laughed but he was a P that
that's why I tell people no Larry is a
funny guy you know he he makes fun of
himself he's he's self-deprecating
hilarious marriages this is a lot
different than you see the button down
Larry that vo that he's he is in public
is a lot different than the Larry that
we saw all the time and I just I was
lucky enough I did it 30 years I did a
little thing for him for MBA TV and we
got together and played some golf and
had a few beers and you know within two
minutes we were just laughing about old
stuff and had a great couple days of
Larry in his life diner son Connor so a
lot of fun well we still we laugh every
time we see that game in New Orleans
when Larry lit up the Hawks and the
Hawks bench is going crazy you know the
fact that cliff Levingston and those
guys they're throwing the towel I mean
you know Bird was unbelievable and you
would just set the Celtic record I think
prior to that right I think a week
earlier and then birds you know like
goofy in New Orleans against the Atlanta
Hawks and the clock and we had we had
beaten Detroit and I just scored 56 and
I'm walking off the corners where you
going I said I'm done I said you know
I'm done Larry good you know man don't
do it Kevin because when I get that hot
I'm not coming on again a week later he
got that hot he looked at me as a player
at about 50 so I mean like didn't
because I told you it was like have the
Celtics record for a week a week later
didn't have the thing for you know a
year or whatever it was it was just
funny because he looked at me during
that game and said you know I'm on fire
I'm not coming out and you know and then
we all got on the ball and there's all
history great stuff safe travels cab
great to catch up with you again thanks
for making time
oh you guys look bad take care guys yeah
kevin mchale Hall of Famer Continental
Tire coaches corner Continental Tire
proud to be the exclusive tire of the
Dan Patrick show no matter where you
drive or what you drive Continental
designs tires for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire calm
cut normal tire for what you do for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]